why not a Tuesday evening and vlog 20
hello and welcome to the nerdwriter
after dark the only place in the big
black ether to hear about the sexy side
of high finance my name is the nerd
writer and I'm here to be your guide to
through the titillating seas of fiscal
irresponsibility helping you in any way
I can to get your assets in order out of
order whatever suits your financial
fancy and I'm joined as always by my
co-host the very mysterious
Reginald circumstance how're you doing
in that reg just fine what's that you
got there reg this my friend is a 78
Merlot by Far Niente the same urine
vintage drunk by the senior associates
of the Blackstone Group the same year
they acquired the Howard Johnson
franchise in 1990 Wow that is vintage
I'm actually drinking a very special
bottle myself here reg this is an 89
Pinot Noir by wooden head sent over by
the board of Bain Capital this vintage
they drank when staples incorporated one
of their very first investments went
public and it's also the wine that they
were drunk off of their gourds on when
this picture was taken tonight I want to
talk about one of the sexiest figures in
the nation if not the world I think you
know who I mean and no I'm not talking
about Beyonce or mr. circumstance over
there this is a man with both public
sector and private sector experience you
guessed it I am talking about the one
the only the irresistible erotic Mitt
Romney mr. Romney is currently in
contention for the Republican
presidential nominee touted by many as
the front-runner in that race though a
weak turnout in South Carolina has many
predicting that this might become a
strip to the waist
mud wrestling match between MIT and the
improbably nubile Newt Gingrich ladies I
know I'm not the only one who wants to
see these two sands shirt but politics
is the bag of a different show here we
are more interested in what mr. Romney
did before he set his sights on the Oval
Office and since the man himself puts
his experience at Bain Capital at the
forefront of his campaign I think it's
only appropriate that we explain and
analyze that experience what do you
think Reggie I think I'm drunk now those
who know me know that there are a few
things that make my cherries tingle more
intensely than private equity but what
is private equity after all well private
equity is an asset class consisting of
equity securities in up
reading companies not publicly traded on
a stock exchange
well nerdwriter hey that sounds like a
lot of gobbledygook to me okay reg I
think I yeah I think I get your point
here so private equity or PE used to be
called leveraged buyout or LBO
it's the practice by which a private
equity firm like Bain Capital uses a
fund of money to buy out a small or
underperforming company to flip it for
profits like flip that house you seen
that show I love that show okay so let's
say that you have a company that you
want to sell and I'm a private equity
firm now the price you put on your
business is let's say 10 million dollars
what I'm gonna do is raise 1 million
through my investors that's the equity
the other 9 million I'm gonna borrow
from the bank
that's the leverage okay so now that I
have the 10 million I'm gonna buy out
your company with 9 million dollars in
debt and come in and try to streamline
all the aspects of that business it'd
make things more efficient when a layoff
unproductive employees a decrease
overhead after 5 years let's say that
I've succeeded and now your business is
worth 20 million what I'm gonna do is
pay back the bank it's 9 million plus
interest and then split the rest between
myself and the investors this is the
basic model of a leveraged buyout how's
that Reggie
so it looks like we have our first
caller here hello you're on with the
nerdwriter
what is your question thank you
well that's a great question Mary and a
tough one see these days Romney presents
himself as a job creator recently saying
we started a number of businesses for in
particular created a hundred and twenty
thousand jobs as of today and there's no
doubt that private equity especially
venture capitalism and farm of private
equity where firms invest in start-up
companies can create jobs especially if
you make a good bet like Romney and bain
capital did with an idea for a
supermarket of office supplies which
later became staples the problem is that
streamlining cutting the fat can often
mean job losses and if the investment
goes sour well everybody loses even you
marry since your accountant has invested
some of your own and shoe fund in the
deal while hard capitalists like Romney
say that this is a necessary risk of the
system and maybe it is but the problem
with the term job creators is that job
creating is never the intended function
of any of these private equity firms the
purpose of Bain taken directly from its
website is to deliver industry-leading
returns for its investors to deliver the
best returns job creation and job loss
are a byproduct and this brings me to my
central point it was Romney and his
peers at the inception of a
revolutionary new industry called
leveraged buyout or private equity who
helped to redefine American business see
these men saw a schism between the
incentives of a company's owners
otherwise known as shareholders and the
incentives of its management to rectify
this they acquired the companies
themselves via leveraged buyout manage
them themselves and gave existing
management an equity stake in the
company in the form of stock or stock
options this is the beginning of huge
executive compensation which gets the
goat of those Occupy protesters the
revolution is more clearly stated as the
total alignment in the incentives of a
company's owners its board and its
management around stockholder value for
more on this as it relates to democracy
in the recession see vlog number four
you can find that link in the doobly-doo
I'm afraid that's all the time we have
tonight on the nerdwriter after
I do want to remind everyone that reg is
a fine guitar player and he does do all
bar mitzvahs weddings and corporate
functions I want to wish you all a good
night
may your stocks rise in the morning and
may your competitors go uh turley
bankrupt Navidad Feliz Navidad
I wanna wish you a Merry Christmas I
wanna wish you a Merry Christmas I wanna
wish you a Merry Christmas from the
bottom of my heart